[Musique]
france beaudoin on s'est parlé de 20
minutes avant cette entrevue et l'auto
dessus c'est et il faut que tu me tutoie
j'ai l'impression qu'on se connaît
depuis les dix dernières années c'est un
peu ça france beaudoin c'est un contact
immédiat je m'intéresse à toi comment
s'est passé des vacances si tu me dis
vous premièrement je vais en garder qui
tu parles en arrière mais c est pourquoi
pourquoi perdre le temps pourquoi pas se
brancher direct sur pourquoi pas laisser
les convenances pourquoi pas une
politesse évidemment mais il ya trois ou
quatre couches seront pas enlevés des
fautes directes sur les mois suivants
mais direction la personne sur ce que tu
as le goût de dire gérer pas de gratter
le bobo c'est pas ça mais
je trouve que des fois on perd du temps
à puis moi je prend pour acquis que ce
qui me pose une question que j'ai pas le
goût d'y répondre je vais te le dire
simplement que l'hélice d'entraînement
aussi dans cape chez vous assurez en
masse mais c'est pas cette émission
c'est très frontal en direct de
l'univers c'est fait pour emporter
allons voir carrément dans le temps on
vise le cadre de l'éviter mais aussi du
téléspectateur ça sent tout de suite ben
c'est à dire que on vise on essaie de
l'authentic ce qui est vrai dans direct
par exemple c'est important pour nous
quand même de faire attention aux gens
parce qu'on sait que quand on est assis
sur cette chaise leur avec la
vulnérabilité avec le direct avec
l'émotion des gens qui attendent peau
avec tout perdre le contrôle des gens
juste de pro savoir pour bien des gens
c'est déjà énorme alors ce qu'on leur
dise et on reste dans votre
questionnaire vous promets qu'on va pas
sortir de là ces bains en masse s'il ya
des choses qui sont trop trop trop
émotif sur papier on va pas les lots non
plus parce qu'on sait que ça va prendre
depuis ce genre jeunes confidences la
personnalité qui était la plus émotive
où il faut lui faire de la gestion
alors qu'ils étaient très très émotif
c'est jean-philippe boutique fini en
fait tu ce que tu sors mais on l'avait
kidnappée à sa défense tu savais pas
qu'ils quittent sans menait alors ça
j'avoue que j'ai book on l'attendait pas
en fait quand il s'est mis à pleurer sur
la chanson de son cousin je pense en
fait qu'il faisait je jouais de la
guitare sur une chanson et des metal
dans numéro d'ouverture on sait à qui
l'on vient de l'échappée si son ampleur
est là en effet
cet automne quatrième rebondissements
dans un balado avec j'ai du temps vous
avez dit qu en direct de l'univers est
né en fait dans votre famille des
amoureux musée ou un choix vous avez dû
se faire plaisir à votre mère oui en
invitant des artistes préférés à la
maison leur portée
[Musique]
je dirais que là où j'ai autant de
mérite c'est que chez nous ce que vous
voyez en direct de l'univers c'est comme
une production professionnelle de ce qui
se fait dans notre maison chez nous
depuis toujours dans la famille de ma
mère tout le monde joue de la musique et
c'est lé beau frère qui surprenait les
belles soeurs on partait dans des
parties avec le corps plein de
déguisement de trucs cachés de monde qui
sortait de partout et un soir
effectivement qu'on avait faits venir
jeanne d'arc charlebois pour ma mère
qu'elle aimait beaucoup est arrivé avec
elle elle est celle qui avait été
pianiste de miles davis à l'époque ça
cogne apporte ma mère à son accordéon
qu'est ce que c'est ça on est je sais
pas peut-être une cinquantaine dans la
cuisine chez nous dans le salon et
jeanne d'arc charlebois et sa pianiste
se mettre à raconter l'histoire du
québec parce que cette sauce de leurs
chansons c'est l'histoire du québec et
là on est tous là écoutez effectivement
il y avait quelque chose qui fonctionne
et mais ça s'est il ya très très
longtemps et il s'en passe des choses
avec les grands ballets ces jours ci
parmi toutes les illusions du produit il
y en eut tout humaine à l'automne ça
s'appelle retour vers la culture
émission culturelle un peu commission
art et culturel qui est diffusée au
world est oui alors laquelle j'adhère
alors la question qui tue mais qu'est ce
qui fait une bonne émission culturelle
alors 2021 mais ce ne sera pas moins de
ces bons pas mais je te dirai que ce que
nous on souhaitait faire en tout cas
parce que tant mieux c'est un homme de
toutes sortes nous on voulait donner le
goût de la culture parce qu'on a fait
des sondages autour de nous qui les
soulagent un petit peu plus officiel et
ceux qui ne faisaient que les gens par
moments se sent pas concerné par
certains trucs culturel honte de dire
qu'ils n'ont pas lu ce livre qu'ils
connaissent pas cet artiste là qu'ils
vont poser la musique les gens nous
répondait vraiment surpris même quand on
a commencé à faire pour remporter
l'émission où on parle des mots donc de
littérature mais des mots en général il
ya des artistes très connus qui me
téléphoner en disant j'ai pause j'ai pas
la culture à s'élaborer en littérature
pour réaliser voyons donc on parle des
mots on parle de 2 alors cette espèce de
complexe là pour bien des gens ce qu on
comprenait dans nos sondages c'est ce
qu'on voulait est assez juste dire voire
6 disponible et ses travaux demain c'est
un véritable cadeau merci beaucoup
partagent et merci